- They did not save your life
- They stole it
This valentine's day weekend
-Everyone gets some action
-How exciting
- Yeah
-I'm back
John Wick - Chapter two
Rated R Starts Friday
- You want to know, don't you?
-Why they keep coming here
-To earth
- Where are the others?
-The ones you are hiding
-I don't sell out friends
-Your world is dying
-Optimus Prime
-Do you seek redemption?
My maker
I do
Ready,  huh?
What is going on?
*screams*
Watch the new trailer now at lifemovie.com
You have the cure
Actually I was just leaving
I will never leave
Accept the diagnosis
Then you will see
Its wonderful here
A cure for wellness
Rated R
Yeah
- Rough night
Rough night
John Wick chapter 2
Rated R in theatres Friday
Just who in the hell do you think you are
Well
WOOOHOOOO
That was awesome
He's so cute
I am groot
Whats that
He says welcome to the frickkin guardians of the galaxy
only he didn't use frickkin
Look out
Oh wow
I tried guys
Aaaaaaaa
When I hear the trumpet sound
Im on a rise right out of the ground
Ain't no grave can hold my buddy down
Dead have taken command of the sea
They are searching for a sparrow
Well lets wait down the river
What do you think I see
I see a band of angels coming after me
Ain't no grave can hold my - buddy down
Ain't no grave can hold my buddy down
Dead men
tell
no
tales
Pirates life
There ain't no grave
Can hold my buddy down
Rated R
Dominic Torretto
Just went rogue
Are you gonna turn you back on family
I'm taking it down Torretto
You wanna play like that
You gonna catch Dom , you're gonna need a little help
You wanna tell me why you just put me in a room with this criminal
You guys are gonna work together
Love to